bonjour bastien alors tout d'abord quel
était l'objectif fin de la réunion des
leaders de gauche ce week end
précisons que celle écologiste yannick
jadot déjà qui a organisé cette réunion
allant de la gauche radicale la france a
soumise le parti communiste à une aile
très libérale incarnée par des anciens
mac ronis télé comme rallier un tâche et
où matthieu orphelin
au milieu il y avait s les écologistes
ou le parti radical de gauche pour
répondre directement à votre question
l'objectif de cette réunion est de faire
converger cette armée mexicaine vers une
candidature unique pour 2022 est ce que
c'est un objectif réaliste
on peut difficilement imaginer un
programme consensuel
alliant des antilibéraux et des sociaux
libéraux voire des néolibéraux des pro
nucléaires avec des antinucléaires des
laïcs avec des gens favorables aux
thèses racialistes difficile d'envisager
les anciens macro nist être main dans la
main avec jean luc mélenchon où le
communiste fabien roussel justement
entre tous ces partis le principal
problème n'est-il pas aussi les goûts de
chacun
oui cela fait partie du problème ça fait
cinq mois tout cinq moins que jean luc
mélenchon martèle qu'il sera candidat à
la présidentielle les 1 subie veulent y
aller coûte que coûte
certains comme la mer paris anne hidalgo
déjà dit que l'union serait impossible
derrière le leader insoumis tout comme
les communistes fabien roussel ou andré
chassaigne ils ne veulent plus se ranger
derrière jean-luc mélenchon les deux
sont même quasiment en guerre ouverte
avec jean luc mélenchon et europe
ecologie les verts a déjà prévenu que
l'initiative de yannick jadot
n'empêchera pas une primaire entre
écologistes alors bastien ceux qui
étaient réunis samedi ont malgré tout un
convenu d'une autre réunion fin mais
cela ne veut-il
dire ils sont capables de s'entendre en
fait cela témoigne aussi qu'aucun leader
à gauche n'est en capacité aujourd'hui
de créer une dynamique autour de sa
propre personne et à quelques exceptions
les union de la gauche lors des
dernières élections locales ou
législatives ont échoué électoralement
les français ne semblent plus apprécier
ces vieilles tambouille type gauche
plurielle merci beaucoup mon cher
bastien bastien gouly je le rappelle
vous êtes journalistes alertés vous êtes
spécialiste de l'actualité politique et
sociale
on peut vous lire bien entendu sur notre
site arte france pointé vers